vous avez déclaré à partir du moment où
on peut tous acheter on se demande de
quoi on a réellement besoin finalement
le passé par là donc je passais par le
besoin et puis à moment donné j'avais de
l'argent puis je peux tout acheter et
non c'est important de pouvoir tous
acheté aussi
une chose que pour réaliser que c'est
pas l'essentiel
mais c'est important car c'est difficile
de parler d'argent c'est difficile de
parler d'argent c'est difficile ce cas
précis c'est plus un rapport à l'argent
cvc a su qu'une grosse bagnole ça
servait à rien
j'ai une rolls aujourd'hui depuis 92
j'ai fait cinq cents kilomètres j'ai
acheté quand j'étais à nîmes je vais
c'est au garage et depuis 92 à l'eto
garage un et je paye la rage bien que
s'acheter une grosse voiture à un moment
donné donc je me suis acheté une grosse
voiture
je sais bien mais comment dans une rolls
moi ça des femmes peu l'image de la rose
est une phrase de barrès c'est tout
obtenir pour pouvoir tout maîtriser
après c'est plus d'argent matériel tout
ça moi je vois plus le truc l'émotion du
casque les choses nous procure quand les
achète qu'ils ont nés au moment où on
les achète qu'est ce qu'on possède
tournoi on les achète sur le plaisir
pour un mec comme moi de m'acheter une
rolls n'est pas plus important que mais
qui travaillent dur pour s'acheter une
petite voiture ouais tu vois le mec a
travaillé dur qui s'achète une petite
voiture est super heureux quand ils ont
soudainement c'est pas moins fort plus
fort que moi qui ai les moyens qui
peuvent acheter une rolls main moi je
vois la vie comme ça quand voilà donc
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes plus dans une
recherche spirituelle
spirituel non je sais c'est quoi ces
religieux contre tout ça
n'est pas que religieux spirituel je
suis dans une je suis d'un
c'est de de comprendre ce qui est au
delà du visible je veux dire les moteurs
il est là c'est sur la voiture
et
ouais voilà quoi oui j'aime je sais je
mais j'aime comprendre que pareille quoi
cette touche à l'émotion jérôme je vois
une couleur blanche moi ça me procure un
truc pourquoi pas ce que c'est je pense
lié à mon histoire et
qu'est ce qu'on m'a appris et qui était
lié à la couleur blanche au moment où on
m'a appris à quel âge donc qu'est-ce que
ça m'a procuré à ce moment là et puis un
moment donné j'ai tout se rapporte à
sable trop et s'ils comprennent empressé
devient obsessionnel fatigue et puis
finalement on n'y arrive pas quoi vous
êtes toujours dans cette recherche
puisque depuis je vous vois vous voilà
vous poser des questions vous étiez
psychanalyse eric oui et alors ça servi
à rien pourquoi non je sais pas parce
que vous avez peur d'avoir trouvé des
réponses qu'il ya toujours dans cette
même recherche à la psychanalyse c'est
très long comme truc quand je vois que
je fais ça je les entends plus j'étais
curieux ouais bon après j'ai beaucoup
bougé il faut se font toujours être avec
le même donc j'ai pas fait ça très
longtemps et puis de 3 ans je fais une
psychothérapie trois ans et
voilà à quoi ces je trouve ça bien mais
je veux pas tomber là dedans aujourd'hui
tout le monde parle de ça quoi voilà moi
je fais ça parce que je suis curieux de
ça parce que sans doute j'en ai besoin
aussi ou voilà pas pour pouvoir vivre en
société pour pouvoir vivre et moi
la chose la plus difficile otto c'est
quand même en donner justement quand on
peut traverser des moments difficiles
moments difficiles dit à soi-même en c1
et l'argent ça rien à voir ce qu'on
représente rien du tout
quand on voit la cuae
et là on peut plus être seul on peut
plus être si on est seul on est très
très mal si on a besoin des autres même
et moi je suis super heureux quand je
suis seul et que je rêvasse et quand je
peux plus avoir ce plaisir-là 1 je suis
très malheureux et je suis malheureux
donc j'essaye de comprendre pour essayer
de nous retrouver ce plaisir là non mais
qu'est ce qui provoque avoir besoin des
autres c'est ce qu'a de pire
je trouve plus grand bonheur c'est
d'être heureux etc sans même vous aviez
pas un grand nom qui vivaient dans la
campagne comme ça oui oui oui c'était
une grande boucle c'est un grand homme
que d'hermitage et s'aimer sourice c'est
mon idole ça nous semble avoir connu ce
moniteur c'est comme ça que voudriez
vivre pourquoi vous essayez pas
parce que je peux très bien
je peux très bien vivre ici je peux très
bien me lire ici ou dans une grande
ville tout en étant seul
je suis à marseille je suis jamais le
château d'if sais pas c'est pourtant ce
à côté mais je sais qu'il est là voilà
c'est
un privilège de savoir qu'on peut faire
plein de choses à voir possibilité de le
faire de temps en temps et d'être
maîtres de pouvoir s'isoler au beau
milieu des gens combien du monde même si
on peut s'isoler concessionnaire m'a
dérangé alors vous avez eu eric cantona
des choses qui peuvent s'acheter mais
aussi des choses qui ne peuvent pas
s'acheter comme la gloire il ya une
étude qui est sorti à londres le 16
novembre
chivu sacré meilleur joueur de
l'histoire de la première ligue
c'est normal
je vous ai dit que je me casse
rien à signaler non c'est incroyable que
ses mots non mais c'est formidable non
ouais ouais c'est beau ça fait plaisir
ça me fait super plaisir c'est vrai et
c'est mérité aussi bien sûr mais sûr que
c'est mérité mais bon
notre marut schiste et bien
je veux faire leur uci
ce joli quoi c'est devant une autre vie
comme s'est passé un truc alors là c'est
bizarre on a fait un truc dans une vie
après on essaie de faire un truc dans
l'autre et puis on est toujours rattrapé
par son passé l'espace bagage lourd une
marque oui c'est pour ça que moi
finalement je suis un jeune âge suis un
enfant quoi tuer un enfant jeune homme
fait un barbu je suis un enfant ça se
passe bien à redire et se passe bien non
ça se passe bien jusqu'au temps mais on
peut venir me propose et rue j'ai lâché
la chance de pouvoir jouer je chausse la
chance de ne pas avoir besoin
matériellement de tourner pour vivre
donc j'ai la chance de faire ce que j'ai
plus ou moins vite faire quoi voilà
pourquoi vous dites ça vous avez
suffisamment d'argent pour pu travailler
vos cuir entier ah oui c'est vrai je
suis entier je paye isf à l'époque du
football s'est mis plein de pognon de
côté alors mais oui non mais c'est la
charge en football mais non c'est pas un
reproche bien sûr
donc oui c'est un village vous l'avez
placer votre argent gelé placées en
assurance vie j'ai passé en action j'ai
placé un immobiliers et voilà quoi je
milliardaire et je peux faire ce que je
veux et je t'emmerde
ce n'est pas tant ce pas de voie là il y
en a qui sont plein de trucs autour de
sa machine et j'ai ça et c'est j'ai
conscience d'avoir ça aide que c'est une
privilège c'est une grande chance et
tout mais c'est si je vis qu'avec ça je
crève quoi donc j'ai besoin
de me sentir exister
de rêver voilà c'est pas ça qui me la
sarre ça me donne ce confort l'accord
mais le confort je suis pas peur de le
perdre
mais bien josiane beaucoup beaucoup des
fautes il y en a pour qui me disent les
cours est sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux